encore un couac je vous le disais dans
la campagne de ségolène royal qui a
suspendu arnaud montebourg de ses
fonctions de porte-parole boutade ou
dérapage le député avait estimé que
françois hollande était le seul défaut
de la candidate
alexandre kara diane richard arnaud
montebourg est connu pour un talent
oratoire redouté par ses adversaires
mais hier soir son humour s'est retourné
contre son temps ségolène royal n'a
qu'un seul défaut c'est son compagnon
silence sur le plateau la bourde est
évident mais la blague ne fait pas rire
ségolène royal au moment où certains
dénoncent un trou d'air dans la campagne
socialiste
verdict un mois de suspension pour
arnaud montebourg histoire de remettre
de l'ordre dans son équipe je rétablis
de l'ordre de l'ordre juste et j'exerce
mon autorité juste
voilà sans dramatiser les choses mais
sans laisser passer un certain nombre de
choses
donc j'ai mis un carton jaune voilà et
maintenant ils font que tous les talents
se rassemblent solidarité familiale
oblige
thomas hollande défend son tour son papa
je suis pas du tout d'accord avec vous
je pense que d'avoir le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste avec soin
dans cette campagne pour rassembler le
parti et le mettre en ordre de marche
dans cette campagne je pense que c'est
un avantage exceptionnel et que c'est
sûrement pas un inconvénient mais chez
les militants la gêne et manifestent les
cafouillages sur la fiscalité ont laissé
des traces
this matter à ma femme ce disque est ce
qu'ils se parlent au moins le matin dans
la salle de bain parce que c'est ça mais
qu'ils se mettent d'accord avant de
proposer des idées par trop divergentes
je trouve que c'est justement ce
problématique parce que ça donne
l'impression certaine cacophonie on est
en début de campagne le parti et son
premier secrétaire ont leur place la
candidate à sa place sans fin alors je
pense trouver l'alchimie entre les deux
désormais il y a urgence pour reprendre
l'expression de ségolène royal de
remettre la campagne des socialistes au
carreau